I'm gonna show you how to write a post
Malone song like I know this is a
generalization really I'm really
pointing to maybe four songs wide
Iverson or rock star psycho
congratulations finding some common
technical things about it tonal things
lyrical themes and then being like okay
that's what makes a post Malone song you
can kind of break it down very simply
trap beat 808 BPM 120 to 160 we've got a
dreamy synth or samples with seventh
chords then we've got the vocals let's
get a trap be going with the 808 those
four songs they have two chords
with like seventh chords
[Music]
[Applause]
roughly plugin
so I'm gonna try to use two chords for
the foundation of the song I'm gonna go
with a major seventh to the minor
version f-sharp minor 7 okay vocals some
a lotta crapping are the hooks usually
three or four notes
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no all of
these things are kind of elements that
you'd find in a lot of other pop songs
like what gives post Malone and special
flavour is that there's usually some
sort of subtext of sadness even like
rock star he's talking about [ __ ]
hoes popping pills but melodically
sounds like he's not very happy
and I think that is the post Malone
sauce right there I'm gonna write about
being always tired I'm always tired
I can relate post Malone has always
tired tattooed on his face slow down I
keep doing this pointing thing and its
really [ __ ] corny but I can't help us
like an involuntary reaction to rapping
because I don't rap often and it helps
me rap when I do this okay I'm gonna use
the word ho ho isn't really in my daily
vocabulary I'm gonna use some drug
references got a lot of pop-culture
references human references Michael
Scott he uses a lot of slang
those devil my duty how many reference
kurt cobain not just for a rhyme but
also I'm a fan of Nirvana post Malone's
known to cover Nirvana there's also a
history of referencing Kurt Cobain and
hip hop he's kind of a cultural
touchstone for a tragic figure and
obviously a reference to suicide or
depression post Malone loves using an
acoustic guitar when he has a chance so
let's try out some acoustic guitar
I think I captured some of that post
Malone sound my raps aren't as tight as
his I'm not a rapper and some of the
rhythms that I use are a little bit
contrived like 20 from those sixteenth
notes I don't think post Malone we're
using a song because I sound kind of
like awkward in like fake reggae I think
it sounds like a contemporary pop song
and if you heard it on the radio you'd
think that [ __ ] trying to copy post
Malone yeah so here it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh they only want me for my money and my
stone 120 on the 101 shifted in my lambo
dripping and flexing no fainting never
take it slow I think I'm killing the
game do you think I'm killing myself
well you get online somebody give you a
light feeling something they ride
chemita Pedialyte
[Music]
[Music]
I'm just doing this to get you to love
me
oh that's okay Gucci belt I'm so friend
got a present for that champagne don't
step on my toes I'm faded let's get to
Smashing
[Music]
ah
before I go to bed
lastly when
[Music]
[Music]
the Cayman Islands kids are getting
escaped to do is to get you to hug me
I'm just doing this to get you to love
me
[Music]
always tie bottom never gonna slow down